come on they're gonna lecture me about
civility but you have me on for a
pretense the book you don't ask me a
single question about the book and you
would refuse to even mention my last
name and I was like you know this is
going wrong real fast all right here we
go this is the Reuben report I'm still
Dave Rubin and I have a feeling that
YouTube may not be thrilled with this
episode so even more reason to subscribe
and click that Bell so that you actually
get notified when the clips come out and
joining me today is the VP of the Trump
Organization and the author of the new
book triggered Donald Trump jr.
welcome to the Rubin report good to be
with you buddy all right here we go man
I'm 50/50 on whether this stream is
going to be up by the time I finish this
very sentence right now it's sort of a
win either way right if they censor you
we can blow it up and make it go
everywhere and then other people will
watch but it's the same that we even
have to have that conversation right
it's sort of ridiculous we're gonna get
to that and that actually has a lot to
do with what you write about in the book
here about all the tech censorship and
all that stuff but before we do any of
that I don't know if you remember but a
couple days you were on the view that
you program and I don't remember that no
one's mentioned that to me since yeah do
you remember that so there were so many
things that happened in that interview
that I was like holy cow this is
everything that I talk about all at once
so let's just try to hit a couple things
in a row here so first off the way the
interview started where Whoopi who I
used to really like Whoopi I think she
used to be a decent liberal and now
she's kind of gone off the the
progressive deep end she couldn't even
say your name in the intro she literally
refused to say your name what does that
feel like when you sit down and you know
you're in enemy territory and then the
way they treat you before anything has
happened well is it obviously shows just
how disingenuous the whole thing is
first and foremost right I mean they
invite you on to talk about your book
did you hear a question in the real
segment look I'm not a baby right like I
get like I'm gonna get hit I get that in
that case you know there's not even a
conservative on my side but you know you
know Abbey Huntsman sort of but are like
there's not a lot personality there for
that kind of stuff so you know
get it I get that I'm going in the
lion's den but like come on they're
gonna lecture me about civility but you
have me on for a pretense the book you
don't ask me a single question about the
book and you refuse to even mention my
last name and I was like you know this
is going wrong real fast but right she
basically said the son of the president
then she kind of choked out djt John Jr
I think or Donald Jr she said like she
didn't say she never said Trump yeah you
know I'm like that it's okay I guess
people know but like what's the part
what does it serve yeah but it does set
a certain tone and that that's been
consistent I mean Rand Paul was on there
a couple weeks ago the way they were
treating him but then a few things
happened in a row that I thought were
pretty interesting so you started
getting hit and you apparently had done
a little research cuz you turn the
question around and said to joy you know
joy you've been in blackface yeah and
now joy has been in blackface she has
admitted it on the view she immediately
said she hasn't Whoopi then said well
I'm a black woman and I know what
blackface is know and Whoopi and you
supported Roman Polanski at when I told
a rapist it so it's not rape rape that's
what she said you know yeah you're right
sodomy of a 13 14 year old girl under
quaaludes you're right that's not rape
okay like if that's not rape I don't
know what it is and now you're seeing by
the way like literally the day after
like it broke like some other woman
accused him of yeah you know so is that
one rape rape like I just want to make
sure we're clear but what do you make of
the idea that they never get these
things turned on them that that's what
was so shocking tonight nobody does it
even though we all know it correct it
was funny because I see that I mean in
the last couple days just doing these
book signings like even these guys you
know will come to the book Sonia love it
I love what you did on the viewing or
you don't want you to be with it like it
was not a funny Torretta Rhett but you
know III think what it is honestly did
so many people are used to going on
those shows they have big viewership
they have big following they want to get
invited back you know they're there to
pitch something and as well as I mean I
didn't just go on there for fun right
you know they're there to pitch
something so they're they're so
desperate about wanting to be invited
back that even though it was there five
thousands episode I don't think anyone's
ever pushed back on them yeah you know
they can sort of say it's it's leave you
not
Jews right there's one view and if you
don't have it you know they're gonna go
in after you and so I guess I just sort
of took their script on them and people
like how much did you prep rest and prep
for that I literally uh like I was like
you know what let me have something in
my back pocket if we can have a civil
discourse it's great if we can talk
about it and again understand it's not
your intention to flip it on that's why
it's sort of held off but it was like
they went at me so hard I figured you
hey if I'm on for three segments okay
hey we'll talk a little bit and then
they'll get rough but like you know just
the opening salvos just aggressive even
the conservative sort of come at you so
I was like okay like game on like I can
play I mean so I didn't prep but I went
on Google for about was like stupidest
things ever said on the view like wow
this was not like a well researched you
know counter-attack meant like it's like
it was good to have something in my back
pocket that shows a lot of that
hypocrisy what does that tell you more
broadly about the media though that they
usually know they can sort of say
whatever they want and I don't mean just
the view hosts but basically sort of all
all the lefty media can say whatever
they want you guys just sort of take the
hits usually and then the media then
will cover their tracks after that
that's one of the games I think most
people won't even go because most people
are afraid of the confrontation on a
live screen and stuff like that there
well you know their concern like me the
difference between me and so many be
like I don't care you know what the
media says I mean some of the guys that
I you don't spend a lot of time with now
in politics and stuff I mean they've
literally had the reporters call back
like what is it with Dungey just doesn't
seem to mind when we cuz I don't like it
means absolutely nothing where do you
think that cut do you think that's
directly from your dad I guess it's just
listen I've been used to it I think
there's a genetic component you know I
sort of joke in the book I say you know
it took us probably 41 years to realize
that we were much more like each other
than you would have thought you know
with my hobbies the outdoors through
this like my you know sleeping on
couches in the Midwest like that's not
his thing he doesn't understand that and
so I think if anyone would have asked us
prior to sort of the viciousness of
politics that would have been like you
know Dawn's the one that probably least
likely and it was like now it was like
oh well they kind of fight the same way
you back us in a corner you attack us
for three years mercilessly
we fight and you know I guess that's the
difference it just doesn't bother me
that
much so I don't I don't really care what
other people think of me it's never been
something that's fazed me that much and
so I'll get my part out and whatever
they say they say I don't freak out if I
get a bad press I get bad press every
day like they try to you know anything I
do and say can be used against Matt I
mean this is relevant cuz it's literally
today Veterans Day in the book I wrote
there's a chapter about sort of the
victory and I say you know after two
years of sort of that just fighting
during the campaign you know when we won
on election night like I was not at all
like excited about it it wasn't like you
know we won a hockey game and it's like
yes hours of and yeah it was so vicious
so the the ups and downs the ebbs and
flows they're so intense it wears you
down and beats you down so when we won
and they're like we got it we I'm pacing
around like a caged animal be like no no
they're good they're gonna do something
they're gonna take what Hillary said
Trump supporters we're gonna do they're
gonna do exactly that I turned out I was
right right meaning they were gonna try
to get that they were gonna you know
protest in the streets they were that's
what she's saying Trump supporters we're
gonna do right they're not gonna accept
the result 100% so I was there like no
no no like I figured this game out now
they're gonna do something so so when
John Podesta got on stage and was like
well I was like I was happier about that
even though it meant we were still
fighting and it wasn't over and then I
was that we had won which is a pretty
warped reality right again what were you
guys tonight
what was that night like though when cuz
Hillary didn't concede that night what
she did yeah it was sort of a wishy
washy concession and then it was like
let's see if we can pull some recounts
turns out we actually got more votes in
the recount but you know so I wasn't at
all psyched it didn't hit me at you know
what we had won and accomplished so I
write a chapter in the book saying when
it hit me was literally like two and a
half months later and it was rolling
into Arlington and you know for the
wreath laying ceremony and I was like
I'm not an overly emotional kind of guy
like I said I can kind of
compartmentalize the hate and just move
on but like dude it'd be pretty hard in
it i we're rolling into Arlington and
you see the gravity of the
responsibility that is you know what my
father has to do right now
like and
I was so happy then to the it all hit me
then because he's the guy in charge I
know he's gonna be such a good leader I
know he's going to get out of these
endless wars and you're seeing it and
like some guy in like left-wing like try
it takes like some of it he compared his
sacrifices guy said they'd made
everything all the BS that we've been
going through a hundred percent worth
because he's the leader now that we need
and they tried to make it seem as
they're like I was obviously saying that
my sacrifice is as a business as a
person over a campaign was the same as
the death of Americans like I was like
honestly I can't even engage cuz they'll
try to build but like no reasonable
person outside of like left wing and
like Vanity Fair and these like loser
pubs that will try to take like anything
you say and dunk on you like no
reasonable human being of the thousands
that have reached out to me that love
the book not one has even thought men
what they're saying
I must have meant was what I meant I
don't think any reasonable person was
but that's what they will do and that's
the sickness that is really out there in
the media in a weird way though do you
guys kind of need that now like it's but
you know a to me like it's sort of
become this self-fulfilling prophecy
it's like the media is awful everyone
watching us knows that they keep
doubling down on lies and and racist and
homophobic all that now like that but
working with you before we ever got into
politics right okay so that let's just
do that real quick I was gonna save it
to later but but about eight years ago
you did my Sirius XM show it was on the
out to gauge annal I didn't want to be
on the gay Channel but they're like
you're gay okay so I guess I did start
somewhere but but it was separate but
equal you know what I mean you have an
equal radio channel but it's the gay
Channel but anyway I I got in touch with
you you came on the show and at this
time again eight years ago you were for
gay marriage your dad was not this is
way before he was running for president
or anything and I asked you about that
and I'm not gonna you can't repeat what
you said basically it's not I'm a living
I have probably said something to the
effect of you know what happy people are
productive people it doesn't bother me
at all if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop yelling
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell